Notah Begay a former professional golfer
now a golf analyst for NBC Sports in the
Golf Channel joins us now Notah how's
the weather over there absolutely
perfect in I mean about 70 degrees right
now and just not much wind and pretty
ideal conditions for golf as far as you
know trying to defend on foreign soil
here in the US to handicap the US team
versus the European team well it's a
really strong team on paper the average
world rank is 11 and which is
substantially better than the average
rank of the European squad but when you
look at the venue what viewers are gonna
see is a really tight very tactical golf
course there where players are going to
be hitting their tee shots to a lot of
the same places whether you're a long
hitter or a shorter hitter and then it's
just going to be come down to who can
who has who has the nerve and who can
hit their iron shots closer and then
make a few putts so I think this year's
Ryder Cup you're gonna see a lot more
holes one with par because Dan I was
just out there walking the golf course
that rough is brutal it's similar to
what we used to see it the old setup for
US Opens it's just deep it's thick it's
healthy and unless you get lucky with a
lie you're not going to be able to make
a play for the green and as far as the
European team your is Europe favorite in
this actually you're Europe's a dog in
this no they are and yeah it's
interesting well I think it's because
it's been 25 years since the United
States has been able to win the the
Ryder Cup on foreign soil the last time
was at the belfry in 1993 so we have
very little success here and no one can
really pinpoint why because typically we
come in with much stronger teams as far
as worldwide wins world rank any sort of
metric that you want to evaluate to
determine quality of a team the u.s. is
typically better but they just seem to
have chemistry they get the momentum
they make the big putts and you know if
you get a two-point lead in this thing
that's a huge
deficit to have to overcome and they've
they've managed to do it a lot better
than we have at least in continental
Europe how big is the Tiger Woods story
factor over there in Paris it's huge I
mean you you should the crowds just to
follow me on the practice round it's you
know he probably gets sixty seventy
percent of the fans around his group and
then the rest kind of dispersed around
the other groups it's just it's amazing
I mean the resurgence of Tiger Woods and
him winning again after such battle off
the course injuries come back the whole
thing it's just kind of injected golf
with this huge boost of energy and you
can feel it over here and you know he's
energized his team and he's kind of
bringing that sort of Tiger factor Tiger
intimidation back to the golf course
you've known him a long time you were
college teammates and we had Nick Faldo
on recently and he said that Tiger told
him at the Masters that the champions
dinner a couple of years ago that he
could barely sit down that he was done
like this transformation I don't know if
it's the greatest sports comeback in
history but it's certainly on the short
list there how do you explain how this
happen and how everybody fell back in
love with Tiger Woods well I mean I was
I was there I mean he had four surgeries
to sort of deal with this whole back
issue and then I was there after the
first surgery and I went to visit him at
his house just to sort of give him some
support encouraged him to sort of hang
in there emotionally and he couldn't sit
up like he couldn't sit up in a chair he
had to always sort of be at an angle
because he just is back really at that
point couldn't sustain any type of
pressure and he asked me to to drive him
to run some errands and we went to pick
the kids up at school and it was sort of
it was you know be honest and it was it
was a heart it was a hard thing for me
to see I mean I've I've known this guy
since he was nine years old we've been
best friends for thirty years and and to
see that he was in that condition and to
know that it this could quite possibly
be the end of you know one of the grace
of athletes in
history of sports was a sad thing for me
and it was tough for me to even process
much less him and then come full circle
and a few more surgeries and a fusion
and then him having to rebuild his
entire game around what his physical
limitations would allow him to do I put
it up there you know one of the greatest
comebacks in the history of our sport
just because there were so many
obstacles to deal with in and he did it
there you know he didn't have any
teammates or anything kind of pulling
the weight for him I mean in golf you
have to go out there and you have to do
it and you have to earn it on your own
we're talking to no too big a part of
the Golf Channel and NBC Sports coverage
of the Ryder Cup Tiger was asked about
his Mount Rushmore of golf he had this
to say and then I get your reaction Noda
my all-time Mount Rushmore of golf okay
well Snead Jones Nicklaus what did you
make of his answer there well it tells
me that he has a tremendous amount of
respect for history in Bobby Jones and
that he acknowledges Sam Snead's
all-time PGA Tour win record at 82 which
he's hope you know may or may not break
over the next couple years so and that
he he really feels good does he think
he's better than Jack Nicklaus yes I
believe he does I do too I just I don't
I mean a lot of people say it's not fair
to compare but I just I don't I don't
know how there could be a person that at
his high point could do it was the best
at everything
Jack was never the best at everything he
was really really good at you know let's
call it six out of the seven discipline
you know you will never see it we'll
never know
I do think Jack's win masters in 8086
was one of the greatest feats in sports
but I do think overall that if if they
were to go head to head and I don't
think I've ever said this on air but if
they were but I thought about it since
I've gotten into television and media
and whatnot
I think Tiger Woods would beat them you
know seven out of ten times really
because Jack's not gonna be intimidated
that that's part of you know Tigers
legacy is you know he he would stare
down everybody and they all melted you
know the guys who stood up to him were
the guys who didn't have any reputation
you know but the guys who were supposed
to stand up to him that that's what I
think the mind game between Jack and
Tiger if they did pair off against each
other because you couldn't intimidate
Jack and Jack's not intimidating tiger
right right so you know that would sort
of cry those were things across each
other out but I mean so much depends
it's it's different than you know a game
of basketball where the dimensions of
the court are the same or baseball you
know golf it would depend on the venue
where would they play you know what
would be the setup what would be the
green speeds what would be the width of
the fairways how much how deep with the
rough be like those would all factor in
but regardless of where they win or how
they set it up I do think Tiger Woods is
you know slightly superior golfer how
does the United States win the Ryder Cup
the United States wins a Ryder Cup by
being patient and disciplined most of
most of our players when they get behind
or they make a couple bogeys they'll
start playing a lot more aggressively
but there's there's so much water on
these finishing holes and the rough is
so high that if they try to if they
start pressing and trying to play
aggressive and overpower the golf course
it's going to lead to more mistakes so
they really have to rely on staying
disciplined hitting to the appropriate
spots in the fairway and then trying to
take advantage of good solid iron play
and just really not try and get too far
behind in any other matches why was
Paris picked well I just think they try
and move it around I mean they try and
move the Ryder
around because for a couple reasons I
mean we're supposed to represent the
entire continent of Europe and majority
of these have been you know played in
you know England and some of the some of
the other more popular venues in Spain
and and I just think it was time for
France to host this event unfortunately
they don't have any players they should
get an automatic berth here notice like
the American five World Cup I agree like
I I mean they had a couple players that
could have been close to qualifying
Victor do Besson qualified for the Ryder
Cup at Gleneagles in Scotland four years
ago and I thought that he might have a
chance of making it here and he would
have been a great addition to the team
but they just haven't had anyone of that
caliber the I think the highest ranked
player for the French representing the
country of France is Alexander Levy and
and you know he didn't he didn't play
well enough to get consideration I would
think do Shambo sounds French and then
they should they should acquire Bryson
to Shambo at least for the weekend I
think that's only know to have fun over
there and be it'll be a great watch we
appreciate your time as always all right
Dan thanks for call that's a Notah Begay
Golf Channel NBC sports camel golf
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]